the symbol of peace he still has a long
road ahead but I want to see a society
where everyone can smile without work
I would to be the symbol of peace that
shines a light on this dark world the
beacon of hope I don't get it tough she
why are your court levels going down so
dramatically I wish I could tell them
the truth about one fool there's still
hope for the future of one for peace a
new generation will rise to take my
place in tradition - some of them play
nice because everyone on this island is
my hostage this is all we can do is sit
and wait until everything's over I guess
don't you think we should at least try
and stop that when I help
are you sure I mean obviously I mean to
overcome the crisis in front of like
giving everything you start and say
everybody is Charlie I mean getting a
lot of requests to do my hero videos
this is gonna be my non-spoilery review
of the two heroes movie that just came
out so I'll explain how it fits into the
continuity what they did with the
characters and how they wrapped
everything up without stepping on the
toes of what's happening during season
three because it takes place between the
end of season two in the beginning of
season three so if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos overall the movie was
great it felt like a giant episode of
the anime series on steroids all the
character models all the animation just
felt a little bit more polished but it's
all the same voice actors and it fits
within the continuity it's can into the
main series so it all makes sense
regardless of where you are in the anime
run like if you haven't watched season
three or if you're in the middle of that
or if you're still on season 1 they
really only briefly reference stuff
that's just happened as of the end of
season 2 they don't get into big details
they do a bit of recap and include
footage of Majora's origin but I think
that's mostly in service of making the
movie watchable for people that don't
watch the anime series so you could
actually come into this fresh and
totally understand what's going on but
it takes place during their summer break
between the end of season 2 at the
beginning of season 3 on this floating
island that's populated by scientists so
it's mostly just the main huee
characters all might in a couple of new
characters in a brand new villain that
we've never seen before on the series
now of the UA characters it's really
just the big ones that they include it
feels like a very self-contained story
and everybody gets really big moments
but for the most part of focuses on
midoriya all might all my scientist
friend who's the leader of this floating
city that he knows from his early days
as a hero and then that person's
daughter who befriends midoriya then
helps all the UA students fight the
villains later the actual story itself
trades on a lot of the main tropes of
the regular series like training the
next generation of superheroes being
really hopeful about that that their
legacy will be just as great as the
legacy of people like all might getting
over your fear of things changing and
not being as good as they used to be
just because people like all might are
slowly losing their abilities they do
find interesting ways of referencing
stuff that's happening during season 3
without completely break
the continuity select lately the big
thing has been all my losing his last
spark of one for all they find an
interesting way of trading on that fear
without completely stepping on the big
battle that he has with all four one
later during season three imagine the
story is kind of like Iron Man 2 with
the stark Expo where you have this big
celebration happening and everybody's
really happy in the villains of the
story use that celebration as an
opportunity to try and pull their heist
off before things go completely sideways
they actually open the movie with a
really cool flashback to all my it's
early days as a hero just sort of to set
up the relationship with this new
character that they introduced as part
of this floating city so like here this
brand new character this is how all
might know sim this is why they used to
be really good friends like I said the
humor the pacing the action all feels
like it does on the regular series just
everything on steroids and even though
one of the problems of any big story
that involves all might is is that you
have to find a reason for him to not be
able to rush in and help everyone right
away they do a pretty good job of
stepping around that while at the same
time allowing all my to do some really
badass stuff there is a really badass
midoriya all my plus ultra finishing
moves scene that they share together you
do see a little bit of that during this
trailer footage but there is a lot of
cool new tech and gear that they
introduce and they find a way to sort of
book in that so that you don't walk into
season three wondering where all that
cool new stuff went this sort of a
problem of Marvel movies where like you
introduce really cool new tech but then
you go into the new movie and you want
to have fresh stuff but there's still
all this cool old stuff that you
introduced in the last movie like why
aren't they using all those cool new
abilities in that old tech that they
developed they haven't said much about
doing more movies but my assumption is
is this does financially wealth and
they'll just continue to do movies every
other year or every couple years that
will fit within the Canon but they are
sidestepping that giant Dragon Ball
landmine where you just have a bunch of
other people trying to do in my hero
movie by themselves that has absolutely
nothing to do with the main series like
thankfully Toriyama is involved with the
Dragon Ball super movie so it is canon
to the main series but there are so many
Dragon Ball films that are not Canon at
all overall I think one of my favorite
things about the movie itself is the way
that it world builds in
bigger way than the series has so far so
the series largely localized to the
Japan area but you get that flashback
with all might where he travels to the
United States like all of his smash
finishing moves are named after states
in America so it would be really cool to
see another movie that takes place in
the past with all might in America or
with the other characters in present day
just in other parts of the world because
you remember the whole premise of the
series is is that superheroes have
proliferated across the entire globe not
just in this localized area of Japan
where most of the series takes place
favorite character in the movies price
still midoriya all might the new
characters are pretty charming they give
Baku go some good moments he still gets
to be both an [ __ ] to midoriya and a
hero helping everyone out during the
movie at the same time which is part of
the fun of the character I think so far
they've done a good job balancing him
walking that line between good and evil
I still feel like some days soon he is
gonna swing to evil for at least a
little while but like I said the movie
is coming out everywhere for the most
part in the next couple of weeks but if
you live outside the United States just
be sure to check your local listings for
when that's gonna happen because it's a
limited release so it's not gonna be in
every single theater everywhere my
assumption is is that they'll release it
on blu-ray sometime either at the end of
this year or early next year but
Funimation films who's releasing this in
North America is also handling the
distribution for the Dragon Ball super
movie in January so we'll do separate
videos about that as we get new
information and new footage but we'll be
ramping up for that towards the end of
the year leave all your anime video
requests in the comments below click
here to rewatch the Dragon Ball super
movie trailer and click here for a brand
new Titans Batman trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight